Oh against what use - did you forget
it's over watches anniversary soon lucky
for you Blizzard has got your back as
they seem to have confirmed an event to
celebrate about a week ago
reddit user failed craft uncovered
references to event 6 in the latest
update to the public test realm on PC
when asked on Twitter when the
anniversary event will start wizard
unceremoniously replied no timing
details yet haha boy after thinking a
ridiculous amount of time into the
uprising events I could get that sweet
Torbjorn skin where you can fully see
his hand I can't wait for this in other
overwatch news true achievements reports
that they have discovered an Xbox store
listing for a game of the year edition
of overwatch with the release date of
May 23rd according to the description
you'll get 10 loot boxes the 5 character
skins included in the origins edition a
baby Winston pet for World of Warcraft a
playable tracer hero for heroes of the
storm and more will be sure to update
you with any overwatch news so be sure
to subscribe
people often ask me dan what do you have
in common with Google well we both love
VR while I was buying a $5 Google
cardboard that we're all flying alchemy
labs the developers of job simulator in
a blog post the Texas based developer
said today is a really big day for
alchemy as we look to the future with
Google by our side we couldn't be
happier the dev plans to keep creating
high quality VR content for PlayStation
VR oculus touch and HTC vive by quite
continuing our mission to build VR for
everyone and doing all of this as the
same silly alchemy labs you know and
love we are continuing to do all of this
with even more support and focus on
building awesome stuff alchemy started
in 2010 as a team of four and has grown
to now staff 23 people their breakout
hit job simulator was anything but a
safe bet but cemented them as a
developer to watch in the VR space so
much so that they recently caught the
eye of brick-and-mortar creator and
voice of Lemongrab Justin roiland
who worked with them to create the
hilarious Rick and Morty virtual reality
in use it's kind of a bummer Square Enix
has announced their intentions to drop
IO Interactive the developer of hitman
in a statement to investors squeenix
said to maximize player satisfaction as
well as market potential going forward
we are focusing our resources and
energies on key franchises and stood
as a result the company has regrettably
decided to withdraw from the business of
IO Interactive the decision has
reportedly resulted in a quote
extraordinary loss amounting to four
thousand eight hundred and ninety eight
million yen or forty three million
dollars in squares financial results of
the fiscal year ending March 31st 2017
Square Enix became IO Interactive z--
parent company back in 2009 following
its acquisition of idols Interactive IO
responded to a concerned fan on Twitter
saying there's a lot going on right now
and we'll have more to say at a later
point for now back to making games
here's hoping
io finds a home as last year's hitman
was return to form for the franchise
nabbing our number 12 spot in our game
of the year list for 2016 and what other
game lets you hunt Gary Busey none
that's what that's been games what news
for today this was a reference to a
one-year anniversary being paper
tomorrow is our top 5 stories of the
week and I will see you then